Німецька система початкової освіти
діє понад півстоліття
і має низку унікальних особливостей
Усі діти в Німеччині повинні відвідувати школу
закон не передбачає винятків
Навчатися удома чи посеред семестру
відправити дитину на море
без рекомендацій лікаря не можна
Навчання у школі – це право кожної дитини,
яке батьки зобов'язані реалізувати
а держава має забезпечити
відповідний рівень освітніх послуг
В якому віці йти до школи
та як довго триватиме навчальний рік
кожна із 16-ти федеральних земель Німеччини визначає по-своєму
Зазвичай дітей відправляють до школи
у віці від п’яти до семи років
Навчання у молодшій школі триває 4-5 років
Від землі до землі різняться і правила
щодо того, де саме може навчатись малюк
Подекуди регіони поділені на так звані шкільні округи
в яких прийом до школи
прив'язаний до адреси проживання
Відповідно, якщо ви живете поруч, то ані вам,
ані вашій дитині не відмовлять
В інших регіонах право вибору школи необмежене
і батьки можуть віддати дитину в перший клас
навіть в інші міста і містечка
За умови, що там є ще вільні місця
Втім, навіть в шкільних округах можна обирати,
куди здати свого першачка
Головне - належно обґрунтувати, чому дитина має вчитись не там, де вона мешкає
Наприклад, якщо батьки працюють в іншій громаді
а тому їм зручно возити дитину в тамтешню школу
Або родина хоче, щоб дитина
отримала початкову освіту
в католицькій чи протестантській школі
Відвідання школи у тому ж окрузі, де мешкає родина, має практичне підґрунтя
По-перше, передбачено користування
шкільним автобусом
який оплачує місцева громада
і який об’їжджає будинки всіх дітей
які мешкають далі, ніж за два кілометри від школи
А незаможні родини,
яким громада оплачує оренду житла
можуть розраховувати і на допомогу
з навчальними матеріалами
Приблизно за рік до початку навчання у школі
управління освіти надсилає
батькам лист-нагадування
ваша дитина досягає відповідного віку,
і вам слід звернутись до школи
Цей лист разом із заявкою
треба подавати до школи
Наприклад, у федеральній землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія на заході Німеччини
це потрібно зробити до 14 листопада
щоб піти до школи в серпні наступного року
У відповідь школа призначає співбесіду
На ній перевіряють так звану
"придатність дитини до школи"
Проте це не означає, що дитина
зобов’язана вміти читати, писати чи рахувати
До першого класу її в будь-якому разі зарахують
Співбесіда потрібна, щоб виявити,
як малюк реагує на запитання
чи може зосередитись на розмові,
чи говорить німецькою
З врахуванням цього керівництво школи підлаштовує навчальну програму
запланує додаткові заняття
або запросить ще одного вчителя
з німецької мови